[Musique]
originaire du venezuela aïssa mais
adriana copropriétaire du restaurant
iberico ont craqué l'un pour l'autre et
pour la cuisine espagnole et espagnols
sont venus en amérique du sud
nous on a honte au mélange de cette
culture à part des non au régime
vénézuélien
c'est comme ici à montréal il ya
beaucoup de culture est une richesse
c'est ça qui ont imité par son sens et
c'est l'aspect riant espagnol tomates
ail et un endroit plat tout simple
ils nous font découvrir leur version des
tapas ces petites bouchées unique trois
maliens comme ça à la maison on peut
préparer toute une table de tapas à ne
pas dire en irak si je veux faire
oui c'est beau un ingrédient marée basse
c'est raté facile pas cher et très bon
on n'est pas contre moi je pense que ça
va toucher le coeur de chaque personne
qui est mentionné là ils n'avaient pas
contre matin on va juste frotter à est
sur le pont avant de frotter la tomate
quand les tomates sont extrêmement mur
c'est parfait parce que on les coupures
à moitié et on fait josé gratter sous
les pins on a déjà hâte au stick à
presse allemande au lift un peu de sel
sel de mer fermement dans certaines
régions d'espagne
on ne met pas die sur le pain
[Musique]
le pan con tomate et en andalousie au
diamant je pourrais déjeuner mais c'est
pas tout le monde qui mangent de veille
et le matin fort comme ça et les bonnes
choses c'est qu'ici vous savez des
options même tout seul avec les jambons
aller avec fromage sur l'option qu'ils
pouvaient manger mon petit déjeuner
comment l'on choisit une pour laquelle à
mon petit a pas avec hyper devez vous
pouvez partager vous pouvez mélanger
avec une porte à qui on n'a jamais assez
zupan contrainte et non ça peut marcher
manger en espagne je suis tombé en bas
de ma chaise je vais goûter comme ça
parce que tout est parfait tout le
panache est tellement c'est un peu de
jambon ibérique sur le pagne quant au
matin et si le bonheur c'est le cal ce
genre bon là ça sert de jambon iberico
de villota c'est un produit complètement
unique
dans les tapas on trouve aussi de
nombreuses variations à base de poissons
et de fruits de mer comme celle ci fait
de moules conservés dans une marinade à
base d'huile et de vinaigre qu'on
appelle escabèche y en a plusieurs
préparations pour escabèche de moi
j'avais une simple dont canal auraient
eux mêmes troisième gardien aïe tomates
pain et on va juste a ajouté le ministre
moi j'aime beaucoup le clic depuis
menten n'a pas pu être espagnol dans un
truc que je fais je retire mon âge j'ai
juste eu un peu de fabricants pagnol
pour un côté piquant fumée le sage mais
on devinait cmo tomates et je fais tout
curieux
après ça on va gérer les coquilles et on
va créer une conserve de poisson qui va
nous amène ta pas complètement différent
sur la table mais avec les mêmes
ingrédients avec ces jeux sont faits
juste de poser la main sur un morceau de
pain plié en trois piliers de ces très
douce très bon parce qu'après ça on peut
prendre des mots de mon prêt pensant dit
non mais
toujours composé de notre trio de base
soit tomates ail effet le troisième
place la soupe salle moreira a
difference gaspacho de tomates gelé vide
c'est plus une émission c'est plus un
tueur se plus crémeux c'est plus pour
manger quand on voit la voilà je mets
des lay
mais la demoiselle et blanchis trois
fois ça y est l'agressivité on va
regarder juste parfum die que canada grc
et des fois quand c'est trop fort mais
c'est trop fort voilà ça va être juste
utile c'est bon un peu d'huile d'olive
pour l'onctuosité et des croûtons de
pain les pins qui a été oublié si les
pins que il est trop dur pour eux
mangent excellent les gars on n'est
juste pas cette précieux comme produit
moi je le garde
on restera rien les robots en bon moment
j'ai un bon cinq minutes
si on aime ça un peu plus ce chantier en
plus avaient quand même comme ça sinon
tard et alors c'est le passé doit ami ou
un choix sûr safer this plus délicat et
on le garde au froid moi j'irai 24
heures juste pour que toutes les saveurs
mélanger ça serait idéal à issam ajoute
une garniture à base d'oeuf cuit base il
y ait petits croûtons série de shows ses
frais je ferai mais en même temps ça oui
le pion
on sent que c'est quand même c'est
complexe et quelque chose qui gêne d'or
d'honneur donc j'oubliais je tenterai de
faire une entrevue ou deux je pense
qu'une telle chose qu on aime de la
nourriture espagnoles sic et à la
maintenance et l issue vraiment j'ai
légère à la mi temps ces mêmes produits
puis moi ce que j'aime la nourriture
espagnoles en plus de tout ce que tu
veux dire c'est que ça m'oblige à manger
la fois conviviale
on goûte à plein plein plein de choses
on passe un bon moment
sega joiret tapas c'est toujours la fête
[Musique]